we make way for the hall of famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst Reggie will be on the
call with Kevin Harlan
that'll be game one Pacers Celtics on
Sunday
Game two net Sixers Monday night
alongside Kevin Harlan that will be at
8:00 Eastern on TNT Reggie how are you I
am doing very well
Theodore how are you my friend well it
is hipster Friday and I'm killing it
today here in New York so as you
normally do it doesn't have to be a
Friday for you to kill it thanks mana
thank you ready we know that we had John
Moran on yesterday and I
I get the sneaky suspicion that there
are a lot more people who like John
Marant in this draft then are letting on
now I don't know if you can take him
number one
but Zion feels like he's more of a brand
that you're getting in a great player
John Marant might be a better all-around
NBA might be better suited for the NBA
your thoughts on John Morant
and Zion Williamson well in today's game
where you've got to have a great floor
general a guy that can control the tempo
on the pace obviously John Moran would
be that guy but you nailed it
when you're talking about Zion you're
talking about a brand and coming along
with design Williamson you're bringing
in all those YouTube followers Instagram
the dunks so if you're talking about
mass appeal a fan base and season
ticket-holders its iron I'm not saying
that jaws a better player but this kind
of goes back a few years and when you
had Greg Oden Kevin Durant
remember that whole you know do you go
with a big man if you're Portland or do
you go with the talent in Kevin Durant
so I think where you're probably going
to see this tug of war go back and forth
between these two players but they are
definitely design will be one and to me
morass would be number two yeah because
and it's and it's weird if you say one
guy might be a better player the other
guy is a better brand
and it might turn out that way was I on
Williamson cuz I feeling I know what to
expect from John Moran I'm not quite
sure how high on Williamson fits into
today's NBA and it will depend on which
you know team
what bottom feeder picks is I on you
know the Knicks Phoenix Cleveland I mean
a lot will have to do with that
infrastructure on where he goes really
for both players but right now we can't
say one is better than the other because
to me there's still really really good
college players I want to see them at
the next level I want to see them with
whomever drafts them in the NBA Summer
League you know that's a glorified AAU
game but you do kind of get a sense of
do they have a feel for the NBA game I
do know this is I am you look at his
body he's NBA ready right now so to me I
think he's ahead of jaw a little bit
okay in terms of the physical aspects of
getting ready for the NBA when you heard
the news that Magic Johnson was stepping
down your reaction was I was surprised
like everyone else look this is the
thing we are all allowed if we're not
happy in our current situation job
you're allowed to walk away I get that
and I understand that but if but if
you're magic
to me you you've got to give genie a
heads-up I understand his point that she
probably may have wanted to talk him out
of it and he probably would have stayed
but you got the big fish you got the big
domino in LeBron to come you have to
assume even though I thought they
dropped the ball with the whole Anthony
Davis thing to me that was a that was a
travesty and to me that falls on magic
because that was part of him but you
would have to assume more players are
coming and for you to walk away after
just a year with LeBron it's a little
baffling to me something else is going
on in that organization in that
hierarchy with Rob Polanco which is
something else is going on something
else is going to come out because
magic I know would never walk away from
any type of problem solving rather it
was a basketball player or from a
business standpoint so that's why I
think something else here is underlying
it but also you can't be in that
position wanting to be liked and Magic
wants to be liked and most people do but
I also look at it as Jerry West wasn't
in that job to be liked he was in there
to get a job done and therefore be
respected he was very quiet he was a
silent assassin as a GM magic was more
out front you're going on Kimmel you
know you're you're a greeter at a hotel
Santa low to everybody and come on in
you know it's just a you have to have a
different personality for that job and
that's why magic wasn't the right guy
for the job in the first place and
you've got to have a look somewhat of a
cold heart too
because and he highlighted this because
if they were going to fire Luke Walton
that was going to fall on magic and
you've got to be able to have that cold
heart you got to be able to look guys in
their eyes and say you're gone you're
you know we're going in a different
direction and I just don't think magic
was cut out for that but look if he's
unhappy with it you're allowed to walk
away my only criticism is he's got to
give people a heads up you just can't
you know have a kind of casual
conversation you know with Rachel
Nichols and other people on your left is
they all hold on one second I mean I'm
just gonna walk over here a second and
then drop a bombshell oh you've got to
give people a heads up that's all
especially in the business world I you
know I still think that that he might
have gotten fired and went downstairs
and got in front of this story to make
it seem like that he was gonna walk away
from like there there's something else
that reg I don't know you don't think he
was fired absolutely not no I what I
personally think this is my opinion I
think something just wasn't right or
clicking with Rob pálinka the views just
didn't add up they they weren't in
synergy between the two of them and
instead of buddy
I think magic decided to take the high
road and be like okay didn't you you do
it I'm out well it may have been hit
gonna be him or me it's either him or me
and Jeanne said I'm gonna keep palinka
and then magic said then I'm out fired
no no no it look it was so it's like
hastily called though reg like it was
one of those where you go Oh magics
holding a press conference conference I
mean it was entertaining but nobody Newt
you sit down with LeBron for three hours
you sit down with Jeanne bust for three
hours and nobody knew anything like that
that's Wesley he was that up I think he
was fed up and let's talk about this to
the expectations because we were all
Jeanne fired her brother her brother
gave himself a timeline if I can't get
the Lakers turning around I'm gone and
lo that three years and it was gone yeah
magic said it himself as well if I can't
turn this around the expectation
probably caught up to magic right he
created them - I mean magic raised
expectations I'm the only thing I'm
surprised about is you got the big fish
you got LeBron now I'm assuming
something else would have to be coming
not Anthony Davis I don't think that's
gonna happen but you know the Lakers are
the Lakers you would think people would
want to play there but I think magic saw
what happened with New Orleans and
Anthony Davis and the backlash behind
that because magic went out front and
said you can have everyone but LeBron
tain keeper that killed his team that
killed their season right there right
because now you have all these young
guys saying why am I gonna play hard I'm
I'm gone what do I need to play for that
was that balls are magic that falls on
magic Reggie Miller will be on the call
Game one between the Pacers and Celtics
Sunday at 1:00 Eastern on TNT if I gave
you the Warriors of the field
and no injury as it is now whatever it
is it is you know that that's as we go
into battle that's what you have oh man
this always goes back to that Tiger
Woods versus do you always want to take
the mess right you always want to take
the field
I do boring major injury
I said no one is going to beat these
dudes okay right the only thing I don't
like is the tweak of the ankle for Steph
in that New Orleans game going into the
playoffs because your normal routine is
it's off a little bit he's not going to
get the amount of shots up in practice
leading up to the series playoff games
as he'd normally would because he has to
come in early he's got to get treatment
so his normal schedule is off but they
should dispose of the Clippers in four
or five games so he will get rest he got
to get ready for the Rockets so I they
do so that's and that is the one team
man if I'm Houston they blew it
seriously that game we did on Tuesday
they could have locked up number two
stayed away from Golden State into the
Conference Finals and now you got to
face them possibly in the second round
but Houston is that one team I thought
they could really push just because of
James Harden but I am going to go with
you can have the field I'm gonna take
Golden State one major injury even with
the curry tweak I'm going with Golden
State and your MVP is well we're not
allowed to speak about things because I
voted this yeah okay you voted be honest
you voted Yanis but I will say this this
will be the closest MVP race ever
because every day and I'm not kidding
you I would wake up and be like it's
Yanis I'd wake up it's James
it's a two-man race so I kept going back
and forth back and forth
and look I just closed my eyes I put
names in a hat and then I just pulled it
out no nothing I wasn't like that
I seriously looked at the data it was
tough it was tough
seriously so when you see my ballot
you'll understand there's a reasoning
behind it no safe travels and tell Kevin
Harlan again thank you for the work that
he did for our open when we were there
at the Final Four we appreciate that so
safe travels but I appreciate it detour
Kevin Harlan is the best I love you good
Thank You reg Reggie Aloysius Miller jr.
the third for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app